[Music]
let me start by saying how much of your
exhaust okay can I listen I'm sure
you're doing that from everyone but I'm
sure doesn't burn up spiritually it's
nice one-on-one right so what I have so
many questions to use the heights at the
start with after loading I'm assuming
you had things were thinking about doing
what was it about Ford Ferrari that said
I want to do business well it was even
before Logan it was a story I've been
tracking actually before I made the
Japanese saga Wolverine
the interesting thing is I came into Fox
they had this idea of the development of
Fox and I came in to see the president
three on that plane and Watts
still is and said I want to do this it
was with Rory
kyria and she was she explained to me
that there was another director and
another package attached to it and then
she gave me the newly freed recording
script for Wolverine and I was actually
meaning the Wolverine started this
daring he just left and just loved the
project and he was fortuitous tonight
was about word for arc and so since then
I've been tracking it and and after
Logan the material would come free and I
jumped on the main thing that had kept
the movie happening thank God
all those years was that it cost too
much and so my big job is to figure out
how to get it under $70 and do period
actor in recent movie with real cars in
real action and not all CG and that's
what the vote was mine also strengthened
characters it's other stuff but I wanted
to really figure out how to make this
thing the way there was both spectacular
a real but also wasn't a ridiculous
amount of money because obviously
studios are nervous these days about
projects that don't feature big things
piece of talent
books or IP or something well that's one
of the things that I'm so happy about
this meeting is that it's such a smart
don't move and it's so wasn't them it's
so all done but I'm gonna say it's so
challenging to make these movies know
that it is I mean I really have to thank
look I mean honestly the the energy and
love and the dollars it's the Logan
really get in the editing room what are
you so excited about and what are you a
little bit nervous about with this movie
it was all about like I was really
excited I looked I honestly was very
excited about the picture my greatest
nervousness was that the tapestry of it
all was was you know my the first cut I
saw the movie was three and a half hours
so was a foolish man and and was it an
assembly cut it was it a cut that you
were like pretty handsome
it was a handsome cut my editors don't
even whatever they call assembly my
editors
Mike mckusker and his team they all they
work on showing me a version of the
movie I mean obviously there's stuff
that's gonna be rough but no it isn't
like sloppy
I mean it's sloppy in the sense that
there's stuff that should come out
because it's too long but it's not
sloppy and that anything looks awkward
and also by the way I've been working
with them the whole shoot meaning
they'll send me scenes I send them notes
I'll come in on a Saturday and go
through a cut with them so what I'm
seeing after about two weeks after I
wrap it's obviously missing visual
effects and set extensions and the music
may be rough and but it's it's a you can
if you've done this a while you know you
know what you're looking at and and I
knew we were when you're cutting over an
hour out of a movie that looks pretty
good at three and a half hours it's hard
because you're having to cut one of
every three minutes you watch when
you're watching it and that's that's a
lot of I guess I'm gonna have to ask the
most important question as a fan of your
movie and your work when are you going
to show me the the 3d version
when can I see that well that we were
talking about doing something at least
putting the additional scenes maybe on
the blu-ray if blu-rays still exist by
the time this movie makes it I think it
will
good I'm confident well we've been
talking to the Fox about that I'm
sometimes torn about whether to have
alternate versions of movies because I
feel like I I literally have an argument
inside myself some filmmakers I admire
just put out there the finished work and
that's that and some put out alternates
and whatever and it's kind of like I'm
sometimes confused what's the best
course of action is it's so interesting
because I mean the famous story is that
Kubrick burned the negative of anything
he didn't use right and sin wanted he
wanted the version he finished to be the
version play it but then you have
moments where like he showed 2001 I
guess the first screening was longer and
then after that first world premiere he
removed whatever it was 5 legend is that
he trimmed the prints yes that it was so
late that he was actually trimming the
answer prints of the movie before
release yeah yeah which there's a hard
splice and all the print sure and but
you also I think about like someone like
Woody Allen and all the stuff that's
missing from like Manhattan and all
these other things that we'll never see
you know I know it's very confusing
question right so I guess my thing is
you obviously see over three and a fire
cut you then we work on finding what's
the essence of the story I mean I didn't
think by the way it should be a three
and a half hour movie it was long and
but by the time we got to like 2:45 it
was a very good movie at 2:45 so it's
just about do we need this do we need
this do we need this and a lot of it
you're thinking about there's people who
just don't want to see a movie that long
you're also thinking about the fact that
that does it work if it works leaner
then it doesn't need it meaning there's
a school of thought that if I can take
this out and it doesn't hurt anything
then I should take it out and we just
kept working till we realized we were at
a point where we wouldn't what I was at
a point where if I did more I would like
the movie less I was at a peak of
thinking the movie was sharp we put in
front of audiences and it was still
remember I'm getting Fox to release a 90
million dollar two-and-a-half-hour movie
and we're going in front of audiences
and they're loving it and in tests but
there's also a contingent that are
saying it's not shark dude
and so I couldn't go backward but I also
didn't want to cut anymore and the
studio was very kind in the sense that
there's a lot of studios that wouldn't
would still be like at 2 hours and 25
minutes that's still too much and they
weren't they we all agreed this is the
best place to stop yeah I'm thinking man
oh I'm gonna do my final question about
the editing and say what was the last
thing or two that you cut out of the
movie that almost made it in the film
do you remember I it's it's not that
exciting to describe there's a longer
conversation between Bernthal and Matt
Damon at a Mustang release that is a
beautiful piece of acting and a long
tracking shot I did with them that came
out because I realized the movie didn't
require it and and but it's the last
piece I took out because I was quite
fond of it the other thing that that you
should know watching it is that the the
in the terms of cutting is that the
races were where the we were continually
massaging learning from sound learning
finding a new piece doing we were really
working a long time on getting the races
right particularly the last almost
hour-long race for those of you in the
audience who haven't seen the movie the
movies kind of a straight drama with a
little bit of racing for almost 90
minutes and then the last hour is almost
nothing but racing it's I always would
say to the crew it's like a reverse
Private Ryan you open with this in
Private Ryan of course you open with
this insane action and then the movie
becomes kind of a Western drama and this
movie is the opposite it's kind of a
ensemble piece building and building
toward a 50 minute race at the end yeah
okay so my final thing so you think that
there's a chance for fans of the movie
like me that we could get a longer thing
on the blu-ray we will see right there's
a chance there's Steve there's a chance
of anything that yeah no one who sits in
this couch who couldn't with you
grinning and begging tell you there's a
chance there's a chance of anything sure
I definitely want obviously filming
these racing scenes which are fantastic
you obviously have a second unit
director I believe it was Darren
Prescott yes and so I'm curious how do
you work with Darren to craft these
things and because they look so
realistic and well done
well that's the credit to Darren and his
team of son guys and race drivers and
are also our car team was phenomenal in
this movie we had a we're running a
incredibly large vintage garage running
at all times on this movie with cars
coming in broken off the set to be
repaired others going out we were
running essentially Shelby American only
we were fixing Ferraris Porsches
Shelby's Ford's you name it and Aston
Martin's so we had a kind of we had an
expert battery of mechanics working on
both vintage cars and some were more
modern engines with a skin on them but
one during another they all had to drive
and crash and then be back come back out
on the road again that was part of our
budget saving effort was we wanted to do
it real but we had to have some kind of
system by which we could put everything
out on the road the real thing Darren
and I worked on was planning because the
most amazing thing after you see this
movie you'll have to remember this
because it doesn't sound that amazing
until you've seen the movie but LeMond
doesn't exist anymore in the format did
in the mid-60s meaning in in the mid
60's and earlier LeMond was three and a
half miles of kind of country roads
connected by just by turns you know what
stop signs they make the turns of the
stop signs and then they go past what
was a kind of older style grandstand and
like you see in the movie and none of
that exists anymore it all looks like
Staples Center in France now it's the
same basic track only it's more
professionally graded and it's got and
professional pits and tons of stands so
we couldn't shoot there so we needed to
somehow put together a simulation of
what LeMond was in the early 60s and for
the erasing experts it's a very specific
track there's there's many turns and
twists and straightaways that have very
specific names and have a very specific
look the you know the Mulsanne straight
is is 2 miles is a mile of a straight
away with poplar trees on one side and
dadada and pastures for cows on the
other so we scouted and we found many of
these locations in different parts of
Atlanta which
we're Darrin ended up shooting that
stuff with us and then the Grand Stand
we built in California at an abandoned
Airport and because if you think about
it if you need cars to drive over a
hundred miles an hour past your camera
you don't just need Road for them to
drive on you need Road for them to get
up to over a hundred miles an hour on
you can't just take it and even race
cars don't go 0-200 in one second so you
need a long straightaway so every time
what this is getting to you see a car
complete one one circle around the
LeMond track you are seeing it pass
through six different discrete locations
California is the starting line where
the with the grandstand the Dunlop
bridge is a different location in
Atlanta then the next set of curves is
another location in Atlanta the Mulsanne
straight is a very rural location of
farmland we found in Atlanta with the
poplar trees and the cow pastures then
you're back in another area of Atlanta
on an actual racetrack and then you're
back in California what does this mean
as a filmmaker means that if you've got
three cars in three different positions
and it's raining to do one circle around
that track you've got to shoot those
three cars in matching positions in
California in five different locations
in Atlanta and then back in California
with the lighting conditions in the rain
and the dirt level on the track and
everything else all matching to make
this stuff cut and that editorially
stunt wise and visual effects wise
physical effects wise there was one of
our greatest challenges is that we
wanted to make all these different
locations pull together into one
seamless reality I'm already giving the
wrap-up signal I have about a thousand
other questions I'm sorry for the long
no no I'm trying to think of what my
last thing is gonna be with you that you
got an extra few minutes no I'll sit
here you I think she'll kill me
her name's Carol I love her don't kill
him right so no matter what movie you're
making you never have enough time you
never have enough money you're I didn't
say that no I didn't say that but I know
what you mean is a general thing heroes
they were very generous in this movie we
finished on time it was very
realistically made no but I'm curious
about though is you so you
getting ready to shoot yeah what's the
thing that you're most nervous about
being besides and well actually anything
about being able to pull off with the
limitations that you're given my
greatest anxiety was that I wanted the
characters to come to life and I felt
like I had I wanted the ensemble to come
to life in the world I wanted to invite
the audience into this world I felt like
this meeting of corporate politics of
the 60s we in for Dan Dahl and and Lee
Iacocca and all his folks and the kind
of hot rodders and greasers and
mechanics of the shelby american world
and then the and then of course the kind
of the elite brilliance of the ferrari
world all these worlds coming together
was what i was most concerned with
getting right I felt like and in an
entertaining way that it didn't feel
like a documentary
you know you'll notice we see the movie
there are no dates or little subtitles
telling you where you are I feel like
even period movies and historical movies
sometimes get overwhelmed with the facts
and I want you to get overwhelmed with
the drama and that was early my big my
big interest is that we have a lot of
action movies these days but not many of
them have characters that you really
care about other than maybe liking the
people who are playing them the that
you're actually involved in these
characters lives and I am always
interested because it's what I grew up
on it's the great action movies where
you really cared about the characters
and you saw their psychological issues
playing themselves out in the action as
opposed to the action just being what
we've gotten to now which is like an
arms race with the last movie can we do
something bigger and better than the
last guy that that's the thing in
amending the the longer running time and
the structure of your film allows you
after that hour and a half where you're
not worried about the action if you will
that I actually give a [ __ ] about who
these people are that's true so the
other thing that helps is when you're
not making a movie and forgive me twelve
thirteen year olds who are watching but
when you're not making a movie for a a
dede kind of thirteen year old mind you
also don't have this rule that populates
the head of many studios which is that
you just need some action every five to
eight minutes or so to keep your young
audience engaged and that you this movie
doesn't have that and
the advantages even financially which is
what you're getting to is that when you
don't feel the need that every every
five to eight minutes you need some kind
of spike of action you can actually save
that money and move it down the line so
when you finally do get in action you've
got all the resources you would have
poured into twelve mini wake up the
audience action beats into one mega
action beat which is kind of what I'm
you know private ryan' even Rocky in a
way is a very light on fighting until
the end and and it's like that these are
all examples to me of where they save
their resources then they blow your mind
in the third act yeah I want to give a
huge thank you to 20th Century Fox from
making your movie because it is so hard
tamela's Steve as Belle I know even then
incoming folks at Disney who have been
really supportive since they came in
it's a but it was a lot of courage on
their part because these are the kind of
movies that studio bosses get hung for
because if they don't work there there's
nothing to blame you can't say oh I made
it because it was a best-selling book or
I made it because there's so many fans
out there can't say any of those things
it's just has to be I made it because I
believed in the picture completely my
last thing for you and I and hopefully a
brief answer I'm a big fan of your work
a lot of people watching this on the
site are big fans of your work I know
you just finished but have you thought
about what you might try to accomplish
next of course are you willing to share
of course not exactly I'll leave it
there and say that let's talk in a few
months I'll talk all about I completely
understand um seriously Congrats on your
movie I'm so it's so so awesome thank
you stand up the good work here thank
you and I'm gonna hold you to letting me
see the longer cut and on that note
we'll see if I can ever offer that Steve
no he said that I'm sad